er nannte putin einen freund und
lupenreinen demokraten er durfte zwei
russische kinder adoptieren seit jahren
arbeitet er für russische
energiekonzerne wer was nervt und gast
bei wladimir putin steht gerhard
schröder in der ersten reihe
jetzt soll schröder bei putin in sachen
ukraine krieg vermittelt haben es war
ein besuch ohne kameras
einzig ein post von schröders frau aus
einem moskauer hotel es soll wohl den
eindruck vermitteln ihr ehemann
verhandle ich hier gerade den frieden
europas
meines erachtens ist das eine aktion
allein in eigener sache gerhard schröder
hat die allergrößte angst dass er hier
in deutschland zur persona non grata
wird dass er als mensch der sich
derartig zum angestellten eines
diktators gemacht hat und sich nicht bis
heute distanziert hat übrigens auch bis
heute nicht von seinen wirtschaftlichen
verflechtungen dass er als solcher
seinen ruf in deutschland endgültig
ramponiert hat
nicht mal der bundeskanzler habe von
schröders moss kommission gewusst scholz
ermahnte seinen parteifreund anfang märz
seine lukrativen posten in putins
russland aufzugeben ich finde nicht
richtig dass gerd schröder diese ämter
wahrnimmt und ich glaube auch dass es
richtig wäre er würde sie niederlegen
kurz darauf wird die spd doch deutlicher
in einem brandbrief fordert sie von
schröder handle und sage klare worte als
das bekannt wurde war der aber schon
unterwegs als hoffnungsträger und die
spd oder zurück ich sag mal so alles was
hilft gerade um diesen furchtbaren krieg
zu beenden ist ja willkommen die spd im
dilemma nicht nur schröders posten für
putin mehr und mehr ein problem auf die
ostpolitik willy brandts wandel durch
handel ist mit putin gescheitert doch
viele genossen wollen das lange nicht
wahrhaben
ich glaube dass es gerade wichtig ist in
schwierigen zeiten im dialog zu bleiben
blumen für den russischen botschafter
nordring 2 bei ihr projekt russisches
gas für deutschland
mecklenburg-vorpommerns
ministerpräsidenten gründete gar eine
stiftung die half us sanktionen zu
umgehen
finanziert von gazprom
bis zum schluss sogar noch bis in die
neue regierung hinein hat man gesprochen
19.2 sei ein privates kommerzielles
projekt das ist einfach einfach falsch
um nicht ein schärferes wort zu
gebrauchen
nach dem einmarsch russlands die 180
grad wende nord stream 2 gestoppt die
mitarbeiter entlassen die stiftung
aufgelöst
und schwesigs regierungssitz r leuchtet
in den farben der ukraine
nicht nur die spd 16 jahre lang hat auch
angela merkel cdu deutschland geführt
und putin wenig entgegengesetzt der
nutzt die schwäche aus 2007 merkel für
ihre angst vor hunden bekannt vorgeführt
vom russischen präsidenten
trotzdem hält merkel fest an putin und
an öl und gas aus russland
wir setzen auf einen zuverlässigen
lieferanten russland sie unterstützt den
bau von nord stream 2 das geht so bis
zum ende ihrer kanzlerschaft
liebesgrüße aus moskau die sendet auch
bayerns ministerpräsident markus söder
voller stolz im januar 2020 via facebook
nach hause
zum einen ging es um die zusammenarbeit
zwischen bayern und moskau und russland
insbesondere wirtschaftlichen bereich
wie denkt so der heute über seinen
besuch bei putin
bei einem weißwurstfrühstück mit us
soldaten fragen wir nach unserer
rechtfertigt sich nicht er habe um den
besuch bei putin gebeten sondern eine
einladung erhalten ich habe lange
überlegt ob ich die dann im frühjahr
2020 das wahrnehmen soll habe damals
gespräche geführt unter anderem mit der
bundeskanzlerin gefragt
soll man das machen denn es gab damals
schon eine reihe von fragen ich glaube
dass es über all die jahre richtig ist
gespräche zu suchen auch jetzt ist es
sinnvoll gespräche gespräche sucht der
horst seehofer der kreml nutzte es für
propaganda im jahr zwei der krim aktion
kündigte das russische staatsfernsehen
seehofer gar als gegner von russland
sanktionen an
dass sie heute erklären ließen dass wir
nicht alles verschwörer kommen
delegationsmitglied edmund stoiber feld
puttinger um den hals die reaktion schon
damals verheerend das irre ist nur dass
solche leute wie herr stoiber und wie
sie alle heißen sie können es nicht bei
einem formellen handschlag wie es sich
gehört belassen sondern sie müssen ihn
gleich die hand auf die schulter legen
oder sich umarmen lassen und das zeigt
in gewisser weise auch den verfall der
politischen und diplomatischen formen
sachsens ministerpräsident
michael kretschmer cdu fährt im april 21
nach moskau kurz nach dem kreml-kritiker
alexej nawalny verhaftet wurde er postet
von seinem moskauer hotel so war aus
telefonierte gerade mit putin kritiker
verteidigt später nicht nur diese sofa
szene er glaubt weiterhin an einen
dialog mit russland
der ukrainische botschafter andrej melik
gibt heute bei bild bekannt schröders
vermittlung sei gescheitert ergebnislos
und wohl auch sinnlos ist gerhard
schröder jetzt oder jedenfalls in
kürzester zeit da sich herausgestellt
haben wird dass er nichts erreicht hat
ist er dann bereit seine aufgaben seine
dienste seinen teuer bezahlten dienste
verbreitet wie putin einzustellen das
ist die entscheidende frage und bis dato
gibt es noch keine anhaltspunkte dass
gerhard schröder auch bereit ist
ökonomische konsequenzen zu ziehen denn
der krieg geht unvermindert weiter
schröder selbst meldet sich heute aus
hannover zurück nicht mit einzelheiten
seiner moskau-reise er schreibt man die
stadt hannover er verzichte
unwiderruflich auf seine
ehrenbürgerwürde
[Musik]